-It is time for "Screengrabs."
Here we go.
-♪ Make me wanna screengrab ♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
-These are some weird,
funny things that you guys
found on the Internet or took
a picture of in real life
and then sent in to us.
This first screengrab
was sent in
by Kasey Hilton
in Ann Arbor, Michigan.
It's an ad she saw for people
who might be considering
a career change.
-Oh.
-Yeah.
It says, "Become a Teacher."
[ Laughter ]
Uh, no thanks.
[ Applause ]
That's the picture
you want to use?
-Chucky.
-Tell Chucky I said hello and --
[ Laughter ]
This next one was sent in
by Ben Cohen
in Nanuet, New York.
He lost a gift card
that he got over the holidays
and was trying to figure out how
to get a replacement.
Here's the explanation
right here.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Super simple.
-Oh, great.
-It's so easy.
Once you find your card...
-Yeah?
-...you call the number
on the back and then, yeah.
-And it only costs $25
to replace your card.
-Sir, it's probably in your hand
right now.
"Oh, thanks."
[ Laughter ]
This next one was sent in
by Treva Bishop
in Vero Beach, Florida.
-Whoo!
-She was browsing Netflix
and spotted this movie
starring Jason Bateman.
Eh.
[ Laughter ]
Eh, not bad.
[ Applause ]
I remember that.
I remember that poster.
-Oh, yeah.
He's got legs.
-I remember that movie.
This next one was sent in
by Tom Vess in Croatia.
-Hey.
[ Audience ohs ]
-That's awesome.
He was watching a football game.
Let's see who was playing.
It was Baltimore
versus Green Day.
Oh, cool.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-"Hey!"
-Yeah.
[ As Johnny Carson ]
Well, wake me up
when this game ends.
[ Laughter ]
This next one was sent in
by Jay Chandra in Draper, Utah.
He was browsing the menu
of a restaurant
that he was thinking
of eating at
and he spotted some photos
of dishes
that were considered
menu highlights.
Let's see what they had here.
That's good.
And...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Tough call.
I'm going to go
with the tandoori chicken.
This next screengrab was sent in
by Jim Cramer
-Oh!
-in Furman, South Carolina.
-Oh.
-He spotted a movie
with an interesting
description here. Says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Save your time.
This next screengrab was sent in
by Laura Cordingley
in Rochester, New York.
She was shopping for a house
online, spotted this.
Kind of a deal here.
Look at this.
It's got 22 bedrooms
and 2 baths.
-Wow!
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Not bad.
-Officially.
-Next was a screengrab sent in
by Amy O'Hara
in Gainesville, Georgia.
She was searching for a job
online and spotted this.
You can be a dog groomer
for Dunkin' Donuts.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Yeah.
-They doing that now?
-Start with breakfast
sandwiches.
Now, they're getting
into dog grooming.
-America Runs on Dunkin'.
-So do dogs, apparently.
The next screengrab was sent in
by Steen Eriksen in Minneapolis.
[ Cheering ]
He was reading some --
-There you go.
-Friends of Steen?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-"Uh, we're here with Steen."
Come in.
Come right in.
He was reading some local news
on his phone
and spotted this ad.
Look at this right here.
This is a...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-"Create Your Own Nut Butter"?
[ Laughs ]
-Seems painful.
-Oh!
-[Both] Seems a little painful.
-We're down to our last
one here.
This is a photo
of a Chicago White Sox fan
that was posted on Twitter
by a sports writer
named Allan Bell.
Allan tagged me in it because he
thought the fan looked like me.
I don't know if I see this
at all.
Let's take a look at this.
[ Laughter and applause ]
He thought that looks like me.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, Allan --
Well, let me try something here.
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
[ Speaks indistinctly ]
-Okay.
♪♪
Yes.
-Okay.
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
-Let's go, White Sox!
That's all the time we have
for "Screengrabs."
If you have a funny screen grab,
email to us at...
We might put it on the show.